je pense qu'il y a une autre raison de
voter la suppression de cet article 1
c'est le débat en trompe l'oeil le débat
biaisé que nous avons sur la question de
la suppression des régimes spéciaux et
en fait il y a deux façons vous avez
choisi deux moyens pour supprimer les
régimes spéciaux l'article 1 proposé par
le gouvernement et puis l'amendement
2057 du président retaillaud qui revient
et je voudrais de dire quel a été ma
surprise quand j'ai découvert que cet
amendement était en réalité après
l'article 7 donc on va parler une fois
des régimes spéciaux ce matin à
l'article 1 et on en reparlera après
l'article 7 comme si il y avait un
problème et en fait je me suis dit c'est
une erreur de rédaction il ne fallait
pas écrire amendement après l'article 7
il eût été plus franc plus sincère
d'écrire amendement après la date du 7
mars date du mouvement social parce que
c'est ça en réalité ce dont vous ne
voulez pas c'est que votre amendement
sur les régimes spéciaux et leur
suppression soit discuté avant le
mouvement du 7 mars mais ce qui était
étonnant parce que vous êtes tellement
sûr de vous sur le fait que les Français
détesteraient tellement tous tous les
régimes spéciaux que vous ayez une
immense adhésion dans ce cas-là
soumettez-le au vote maintenant c'est
amendement avec l'article sur les
régimes spéciaux peut-être même les
Français vous soutiendront peut-être
même vous déclencherez une manifestation
aussi de soutien votre amendement de
suppression des régimes spéciaux donc
une grande manifestation préture et
autant de gens dans la rue pour votre
amendement qui en a contre cette réforme
donc l'amendement sur les régimes
spéciaux devraient être là il n'est pas
là nous voterons donc à cet instant la
suppression de l'article 1 avec
notamment
voilà il est 11h52 sur l'antenne
[Musique]